[Music]
speaking of your dad not understanding
what you did my dad backstage at this
show I want to tell you two things I say
one thing about your father who I love
very much
his voice is exactly the voice of Peter
Griffin from Family Guy and I'm not I'm
not saying that as an insult or anything
he just has that he has a very strong
accent and when he started to talk I was
like he's he's the dad on well he sounds
like him I wish we had the voicemail
from him or something we could play it's
very it's it's a very strong and people
accuse me all the time of having a
Boston accent and I talk about this on
my show tonight but I of losing it
intentionally and I didn't I didn't even
know I had one cuz when you grow up in
Boston you don't know you have a boss an
axe right and then years go by and I'm
in show business and I'm living in
different places and I you know you you
lose your ear for it and then recently
my parents showed me super 8 home movies
of me from I don't like you know when I
was six yes and it really was like we're
gonna go to the moon we will not
tolerate I was in Hawaii I was doing
Kennedy speeches talking a lot about
Khrushchev we will not tolerate this
aggression but I don't know what
happened to it just went away and yeah I
can hear yours but yours is clearly gone
away someone it definitely has in fact I
think mine just showed up in 97 when
Good Will Hunting was popular yeah I
never had it you didn't have it I didn't
have it in Lexington we didn't have it
and then we tried it I remember trying
it and my preppy high school I'd be like
we're gonna hang out Saturday people
like what Saturday we're gonna hang out
south
I'm real sorry my father said to me my
Peter Griffin father said I thought it
would be fun you know what's fun to have
them here I thought they'd have all
these showbiz questions Mike the one
question my father goes Peter that's how
he sounds exaggerated uh Megan I and
Brian the dog were wondering he goes
Stewie
thank you that was gracious that was not
that good
he's taking yeah yeah I learned to just
take half my life has been pity applause
and I just I just take it I used to go I
go now I'm just like give me more must
get approval what kind of car does cold
and drive it's all I wanted to know and
I said dad Conan's doing well for
himself and then my father goes really
had no con man that's been on TV for 20
years right might be okay I had you know
God rest his soul he's no longer with us
but I had an uncle
true story who wanted me to be a lawyer
and you know when I was all those years
I was writing on starting out live
writing for The Simpsons you know yes
career is working out and he kept saying
not too late
and then I get the labor place David
Letterman would get my own late-night
show and like still three years anybody
was like I'm just saying as a lawyer
yeah you get to direct and write and act
you the whole thing oh you want me to
leave this show to go be a lawyer and
yes he did he thought there's still time
I've seen what you're doing you could
still oh my god yeah I think he might be
on to something
well it's funny because comedians are
often in the search for legitimacy
something that they can understand and
honestly I'm sorry to end on a sweet
note but you've given me that so much
with my family now they understand what
a TV show is they know who you are so
you know this Thanksgiving will be
different from the everybody like yeah
it's a nice thing well you know what's
what's is the thing I always have told
you from the beginning is you're the
perfect host for the Pete Holmes show
you're such a we looked we went to the
phone book and we knew it had to be Pete
Holmes complicated to explain why this
whole thing is a business write-off yeah
no III mean this I do mean this like an
attempt to be as sincere you are such a
naturally funny and likeable person and
I'm just very happy that you're doing
you're doing exactly what you should be
doing and and you're doing such a great
show and doing such a great job and it's
just a pleasure crime is going it
[Music]